So we're going to talk about
conscientiousness again today.
MMM.
Its division into industrious in
orderliness is relatively new.
Those separable elements of
conscientiousness of only or you're
going are,
I've only been established since 2007 I
talked to you a couple of weeks ago
about the relationship between the
relationship that I was hypothesizing
between disgust,
disgust,
sensitivity,
contamination and dominance,
hierarchy status,
right?
And I was trying to tie that into
mmm.
The degree to which someone's belief
systems would assure their status and
safety in the world.
And I want to continue with that
discussion today
and narrow it,
narrow it to some degree as,
as well as broadening it and others.
Okay.
So conscientiousness is a sub element of
the meditates stability and the
correlation between industriousness and
orderliness is relatively low.
Given that there are two elements of the
same trait.
So for openness and intelligence,
you see that there's a correlation of
0.35 that's the lowest plasticity,
plasticity aspect,
inter correlation.
And then for conscientiousness it's r
equals 0.39 for industriousness and
orderliness.
Now here's the basic items for
orderliness and industriousness.
So for orderliness,
its leaves belongings around,
obviously that's negatively scored.
Likes order,
keeps things tidy,
follows a schedule,
is not bothered by messy people,
wants everything to be just right is not
bothered by disorder,
dislikes.
Routine seals sees that rules are
observed,
wants every detail taken care of and for
industriousness carries out his or her
plans,
wastes time negatively scored,
finds it difficult to get down to work
again,
negatively scored,
messes,
things up,
finishes what he,
she starts,
doesn't put his or her mind on the task
at hand,
gets things done quickly,
always knows what he or she is doing.
Postpones decisions and is easily
distracted.
There's a decisiveness that seems to go
along with industriousness and
efficiency.
With orderliness,
there seems to be something that's
associated with the desire for
categorical stability.
Now I have a sneaking suspicion that our
propensity to categorize the human
propensity to categorize is more tightly
associated with disgust sensitivity than
we might think.
And the reason I believe that is because
we're omnivores and that means that we
have to make a lot of very complicated
decisions about food.
Now
here's part of the problem with
conscientiousness.
There's no theoretical model,
there's no neuropsychological model.
So we don't know how to integrate
conscientiousness into,
into neuroscience in general.
There's no psychological model except
that we know you can measure it with
self report and there's no
pharmacological model.
So we have no idea.
For example,
with anxiety.
So neuroticism,
Serotonin,
Serotonin reuptake inhibitors and
Benzodiazepines,
barbiturates,
an alcohol all work to decrease negative
emotion and dopamine agonists work to
increase positive emotion.
And oxytocin works for agreeableness.
It heightens agreeableness.
Um,
and you can even do pharmacological
manipulations to change openness.
So for example,
one of the most recent studies done on
siliciden mushrooms,
it was the first study done on
psychedelics for,
for probably 40 years,
showed that,
okay,
one dose of Psilocybin mushrooms
produced a one standard deviation
increase in openness one year later,
which is staggering.
It's a huge change and it seems
permanent.
So,
so you see,
even though the big five was developed
statistically,
that the details are being filled in
constantly from a structural and a
pharmacological perspective.
But conscientiousness is a tough one.
And it's also partly because our animal
models of conscientiousness are not well
developed.
You know,
you could make a case in some sense that
human beings are the only creatures that
work in that we'll forego pleasures in
the moment for increased security and
opportunity in the future.
And so that and since conscientiousness
seems to be integrity tied up with that,
it also seems to indicate that it's a
like a fairly high order,
emotional,
motivational cognitive attribute.
Here's a problem.
The classic neuropsychological
story I suppose is that the dorsal
lateral prefrontal Cortex,
which is the part of the cortex that's
expanded particularly rapidly among
human beings,
is associated with planning and abstract
thinking.
And there seems to be very little doubt
about that.
However,
the correlation between Dorsolateral
prefrontal function,
which is basically the cognitive
functions are very much akin to fluid
intelligence.
The correlation between Dorsolateral
prefrontal function and
conscientiousness is basically zero.
So,
and I believe the reason for that is
that
the ability to abstract task,
that that conscientiousness has
something to do with implementation of
abstraction into behavior.
Whereas abstraction requires that you
remove the obstruction from the behavior
and
run simulations on the abstraction in in
an imagine it in a space of imagination.
So that you can investigate the
consequences of different courses of
action in the absence of acting them
out.
It's quite interesting that despite the
fact that it's a neuropsychological
truism,
that the prefrontal cortex is involved
in the inhibition of behavior and the
control of behavior from a statistical
point of view or psychometric point of
view.
That doesn't seem to be the case at all.
I think actually what happens is that
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex can
help you organize nicely arranged
hierarchical goal structures and that
those can regulate your behavior,
but that doesn't mean that there's any
direct relationship between
cognitive function and behavioral
regulation.
Conscientiousness is being defined by
Roberts as the tendency to be planful
organized task and goal oriented and
self controlled it to delay
gratification and follow norms and
rules.
It sounds like a cognitive attribute.
You know so much of that planful,
organized,
goal-oriented,
all sounds like higher cognitive
function,
but
it doesn't seem to be.
It seems to be,
it seems to be associated with something
else.
That's a big mystery.
Now here's some consequences of
conscientiousness.
It's strongly related to life
satisfaction and happiness.
There's a number of studies that show
that and the reason seems to be I
suspect is that if you're a
conscientious person and so you run your
conscientious life across time,
you build a rather orderly and
predictable and stable environment
around you in multiple ways and one of
the ways to not be anxious is
to be low in trait neuroticism,
but another way to not be anxious is not
to have anything to be anxious about and
you know perfectly well from your own
experience that if you adopt an
unconscientious attitude to a task that
you've sent,
that you've set for yourself,
the probability that you're going to
experience negative emotion as a
consequence of that is very high.
It might be as the deadline approaches
and you haven't done what you had
contracted with yourself to do or maybe
if you're particularly resistant to
negative emotion,
maybe the negative emotion only kicks in
afterwards when as a consequence of
failing to do what you said you were
going to do,
you fail at the task,
but either way the consequences come
rolling in.
An interesting study by Faye Yard in
2012 showed that conscientiousness was
associated with specific emotions and
overall negative emotion,
but was most strongly associated with
guilt.
So within this situation,
guilt actually turns out to be a good
thing.
Conscientiousness was negatively related
to guilt experience,
but positively related to guilt
proneness.
So that's kind of interesting because
what it suggests is that if you are,
if you use your guilt to guide you such
that you stopped doing things that make
you guilty,
you're less likely to feel guilt as a
consequence of doing something wrong
because you're won't be doing something
wrong.
So,
so conscientious miss seems to be
hovering around the guilt,
shame,
disgust,
nexis in some way that we haven't really
sorted out yet
since dividing conscientiousness up
until orderliness and industriousness,
we've started to understand somewhat
more clearly the temperamental basis of
political preference.
Conservatives tend to be ordered like,
and low and openness.
Now orderly people,
well they make good roommates unless
they're,
you know,
they've got to the point where they're
completely obsessive,
you know,
cause everything trails off into
catastrophe.
If you push any trait too far,
there's a cliff over which you'll fall
orderly.
People seem to be good at process
management.
You know,
they make sure that everything is
sequenced properly,
that it runs properly.
And you can understand that in many
situations that's going to be an
incredibly useful trade.
It's useful in scientific endeavor
because if you're doing data with
spreadsheets,
full of numbers,
if you transpose one row,
you're done right?
That's the end of the study.
You can't make one mistake in a
spreadsheet.
It has to be perfect,
especially when you can make
catastrophic mistakes with computers,
right?
Because they're very,
very good at making major mistakes.
So you have to be very orderly to be a
scientist.
Um,
industriousness seems to be a better
predictor of
phenomena like grade point average,
but orderliness still has its place in
assuring that complex procedures are
carried out properly.
Orderly.
People also seem to be more discussed
and sensitive.
They have a preference for order and
tradition,
and they're not particularly
egalitarian.
So they're,
they're hierarchical.
And maybe that's because hierarchies are
more efficient.
I mean,
the problem with egalitarian
organizations is that
they can't organize themselves along any
access.
So you saw that,
for example,
with the,
what do they call those people in York,
in central park after the 2008 crash.
What was it occupy?
Yeah.
I mean it was a chaotic demonstration
and no doubt there was something to
demonstrate against,
but the egalitarian left wingers who
were running the organization couldn't
figure out what they wanted or what to
say.
So that's a problem from a political
perspective to some degree,
because it means the right wing is going
to have an advantage over the left wing
on almost a permanent basis because
they're going to be better at
organizing.
Now they left wing is more open,
so they're going to be more creative.
So hopefully that's enough of an edge to
keep the two sides properly balanced.
Orderly.
People also make harsh judgments of
moral transgression.
I think that probably goes along with
the hierarchy,
you know?
So I think for orderly people,
there's a pretty steep hierarchy of,
of good versus bad or,
or maybe good versus evil.
And that each of the tiers in that
hierarchy or clearly demarcated and
their demarcated morally,
it's better to be at the top.
Yeah,
and it's worse to be at the bottom dock
near Calc,
calc Keltner,
I think,
sorry,
I can't pronounce his name properly.
At the moment has andy and Jonathan
Haidt if talked about the moralization
of purity and they believe that
one of the things that distinguishes
the top of an orderly hierarchy from the
bottom of an orderly hierarchy is that
the people at the top who are following
the rules fall into the metaphorical
category of pure
and the people at the bottom who aren't
following the rules fall into the
metaphorical category of the impure.
And you can also see to some degree if
you use your imagination a bit how
that's mapped onto dietary preferences,
especially in religious systems because
there are pure foods and pure ways of
preparing food is an impure foods and
impure ways of preparing foods.
And you also see the same thing emerge
in modern political western political
discourse where people spontaneously
organize themselves into groups of
different self proclaimed morality based
on what they choose to eat.
It looks like it's something very deeply
rooted inside people.
I think it's probably also potentially
also associated with the fact that at
least since we've had agriculture and
reasonably large settlements,
okay,
we had to be pretty orderly with regards
to our agricultural store houses because
if you're not orderly when you store
food,
then rats and insects eat all of it or
it gets moldy if it's damp and then it
gets rotten and then you can't eat it
and then you starve to death.
So it's,
it's not a good outcome.
So I think there's a number of factors
that have congregated together to align
that disgust sensitivity system and the
orderliness system and the system of
harsh judgment and the ideas of purity
and impurity to bring them all into one
form of alignment.
We wrote a paper a while back,
which hasn't been published yet.
Jacob Hersch,
who's the first author on this paper
entitled it conservatism as a social
immune system.
And I'm going to read you a little bit
of the intro from this paper.
Disgust is considered to be one of the
basic human emotions defined by a strong
revulsion and desire to withdraw from an
eliciting stimulus or event.
It's a very embodied emotion.
So it's anxiety,
makes an excitement,
makes your heart race well,
that's one thing,
but disgust makes your stomach churn,
you know,
and it's associated with vomiting and,
and uh,
and tremendous aversion.
It's also very,
very unpleasant emotion.
It might be the most unpleasant emotion.
It's hard for modern people to judge
that because our societies are so well
organized that we almost never come into
contact with anything that's disgusting.
It's all put away.
So,
and you can understand why,
because many things that are disgusting
are actually contaminated and produce
pathology,
their illness generators.
So it's not an arbitrary judgment.
Physically disgust is accompanied by a
distinct facial expression involving
constriction of the oral and nasal
cavities.
Remember when we watched the crumb
video,
one of the things that the chrome
brothers typically got from women that
they were trying to approach was a
disgust facial expression,
and that seems to be associated with the
idea of lowly status and contamination
and the desire to,
to close yourself off from the offending
source.
Evolutionary models of disgust proposed
at this emotion evolved to help us avoid
contaminated or harmful foods or other
potential sources of disease such as
sexual contact.
No.
You know,
we know that if you arrange creatures in
a dominance hierarchy and then you run a
pat a pathogen through the population
and infectious disease,
then the population tends to die from
the bottom up,
which means that the animals or people
at the bottom of the dominance hierarchy
who are chronically more stressed are
much more likely to be carriers of
infectious agents and much more likely
to die from that.
Now,
I don't know what the stats are for
sexually transmitted diseases.
Oh,
I should've looked that up,
but I would suspect that the same thing
probably applies there.
That as you construct it,
socioeconomic hierarchy,
the probability of trends of acquiring
sexually transmitted disease decreases
as you move up the hierarchy
in addition to its role in directly
helping to expel harmful foods from the
body.
Disgust also forms an important
component of the behavior.
Let me UN the suite of psychological
mechanisms that aid in the detection and
avoidance of potential contaminants
before they can make contact with the
body.
Okay.
The other thing that we should never
forget is that the reason we can all say
it here,
so clean and well put together,
it's fundamentally because the plumber's
produced to transformation and western
North American and Western society a
hundred years ago,
and by getting rid of all of the
contaminants that were associated with
poor plumbing,
we cranked our life expectancy up
tremendously.
So it's another example of the actual
relationship between sensitivity to
discussed and longevity.
We also know that conscientious people
have better standards of hygiene than
unconscientious people and they do live
longer.
Discussed may have its origins in the
protection against physical
contamination.
A number of studies have implicated
disgust responses in moral decision
making,
inducing disgust responses,
whether via a follow order,
at disgusting work environment or
recalling a disgusting experience led
individuals to assign harsher
punishments to others who had committed
moral transgressions.
Harsher moral judgments could even be
induced,
falling the consumption of a bitter
drink.
Bitter taste tends to evoke a disgust
response not because all bitter tastes
are poisonous but because most poisonous
tastes are bitter.
In addition,
the same disgust related facial
expressions or observed in response to
unpleasant tastes,
disgusting photographs and receiving
unfair treatment in an economic game.
Concerns about cleanliness and feelings
of disgust have likewise being related
to political attitudes.
Situational reminders of the importance
of physical cleanliness such as asking
participants to wipe their hands with
antiseptic wipes tends to increase self
reported political conservatism such a
finding is consistent with the notion
that purity tends to be valued more by
conservatives than by liberals.
Individuals who report being disgusted
more easily also tend to hold more
conservative political views on topics
including abortion,
gay marriage,
tax cuts and affirmative action.
In addition to the effects that have
emerged when using self reported disgust
sensitivity,
more conservative political views have
also been associated with stronger
physiological reactivity to disgusting
images.
In particular,
a large literature is converged on the
notion that there are two core
dimensions of conservatism,
resistance to change and tolerance of
inequality.
Resistance to change reflects the extent
to which people wish to maintain the
status quo.
While tolerance of inequality reflects
the acceptance of an unequal
distribution of resources and
opportunities within the society.
Now,
you know,
we talked about this already.
It's a complicated issue because
if you're absolutely egalitarian nerve
in your orientation,
then you have to make the presumption
that all differences in hierarchical
status are fundamentally unjust,
okay?
If you're absolutely hierarchical in
your orientation,
then you have to make the assumption
that the distribution of resources that
obtains currently is a consequence of
justice,
right?
The people at the top deserve to be
there and the people at the bottom
deserve to be there.
Now,
as we've already discussed,
the situation is complicated by the fact
that there seems to be some truth in
both claims and so far is
conscientiousness and intelligence
predict longterm socioeconomic status
and that conscientiousness and
intelligence to seem to be associated
quite strongly with competence.
Then the degree to which they predict
social status seems to indicate that the
structure is just the fact that people
are brought down the dominance hierarchy
for all sorts of reasons that have
nothing to do with their intrinsic
competence or or their willingness to
engage in productive activity weakens
the conservative argument because there
are certainly cases where the
distribution of resources can be seen to
be fundamentally unjust.
I think one of the things that happens
with political belief is that you can
think about political beliefs as
heuristics and heuristics are
unconscious rules.
They're really algorithms that people
use to address large sets of data to
simplify them so that they're not,
they're not drowning in complexity.
The system is just,
well,
that's a simplification.
It means there's all sorts of things
that you don't have to think about.
This system is unjust is is it is a
heuristic oversimplification as well and
it means that you don't have to think
your way through the complexities of the
actual topic that you're dealing with
and what seems to be happening is that
the temperamental factors that we've
discussed so to speak reflect the use of
heuristics that are grounded deeply in
motivation and emotion.
Yeah.
The two dimensions,
resistance to change and tolerance of
inequality appear roughly aligned with
social and economic conservative
conservatism as expressed in the
constructs of right wing
authoritarianism and social dominance
orientation respectively.
The core facets of conservatism are also
closely related to the two higher order
value dimensions described in moral
foundations theory which reflect
preference for order and tradition on
the one hand and preferences for
egalitarianism.
On the other.
Importantly,
the motivational basis of these two
dimensions appears to vary independently
from one another with an individual's
overall political attitudes on it.
Right.
Left spectrum emerging from the relative
balance.
Okay.
These motives are also strongly rooted
in basic personality characteristics
such that preferences for order and
tradition are associated with higher
levels of orderliness,
not industriousness and politeness,
which is an aspect of agreeableness as
well as with lower levels of openness
and intellect and contrast.
Preferences for egalitarianism are
uniquely associated with compassion and
aspect of agreeableness.
Political conservatism can be thought of
as a social immune system reflecting the
extension of pathogen avoidance
mechanisms to the integrity of the
social system.
So the idea there,
the metaphorical idea,
look,
if you're egalitarianism,
everyone's a big family.
That's the core metaphor.
Um,
I think that's part of the reason that
women are more agreeable than men.
They're are more compassionate than men,
and it's necessary for them to be more
compassionate than men because they have
the obligation or opportunity to concern
themselves with the egalitarian
distributors,
distribution of resources within the
family unit.
If you're
orderly,
the fundamental metaphor,
it doesn't seem to be family.
The fundamental,
fundamental metaphor seems to be body
and the purity of the body and so,
and the vulnerability of the body.
That's another element of it.
Just as the behavioral immune system is
being conceptualized as helping to
maintain the purity integrity of an
individual body,
so to may the same pathogen avoidance
system help to maintain the abstract
integrity of the social order.
We don't call our society a body of laws
for nothing.
We also tend to symbolize countries as
people.
So
you can say things like England took
steps to,
or France recently decided to,
and so there's the idea that each state
can be represented as a body.
You could also say that a hereditary
monarch like Queen Elizabeth,
it's such a powerful figure because she
embodies in her actual being,
the concept of the state.
The state is a body.
It's actually a body of laws,
and in so far as you are bound by that
body of laws,
you're all acting out the same body
because you're mimicking the same set of
principles that describe the way that
you orient your behavior and your
perception.
So these are,
these are archetipal metaphors.
That's one way of thinking about it.
And they have consequences.
The social immune system would help to
maintain order by suppressing any
actions or individuals that deviate from
a group's accepted social traditions.
If you're,
if
the cells in your body deviated enough
from the traditions of the other cells,
then what you develop is cancer.
So there's this idea,
there's,
it's not only an idea,
there's this,
there's this fundamental reality that a
certain amount of
stability and safety is to be held in
obedience to,
uh,
structure of authority.
It has been reported that regions with
higher levels of disease prevalence tend
to be associated with higher levels of
social conformity and autocratic rule.
Individuals who feel more vulnerable to
disease likewise report higher levels of
ethnocentrism,
xenophobia.
And one of the things we do know about
socioeconomic status is that people who
are lower on the socioeconomic hierarchy
or more disgust sensitive.
Now the reasons for that or to exactly
clear,
because people on the lower end of the
socioeconomic distribution on average
also tend to have lower iqs and lower
iqs are associated with increased
disgust sensitivity.
So there's the confounding effect of
intelligence.
But by the same token,
if you're at the bottom of the dominance
hierarchy,
you are more prone to infectious disease
because you're,
you're stressed and vulnerable,
so there's real,
there's real reasons for you to be
careful about what you expose yourself
to if you're just clinging on to the
bottom of the hierarchy with both hands
or with one hand.
Yeah,
so it's basic concerns about pathogen
avoidance.
Me That's contributed to the desire for
order and tradition among conservatives
along with the harsh moral judgements
associated with violations of the social
order.
Because one of the things that's,
it's not easy to understand,
it's like you see this,
you see this a lot in the United States
where the attraction of Republican
politics isn't limited to those at the
top of the socioeconomic ladder.
In fact,
the Republicans draw tremendous support
from people who were in the lower strata
of the socioeconomic hierarchy.
Even though it seems quite clear by some
standards that the policies that the
Republican's promote are not policies
that are going to help people who are at
the bottom of the socioeconomics
distribution if they stay there.
Now you could argue that the reason that
the poor republican support the
Republicans is because they see
themselves as able to climb the
hierarchy and so they're voting their
dream and north the reality,
but you could also make a case.
I believe that
the people at the bottom of the
hierarchy are already so stressed that
if you add more variability into the
system,
then that increases the probability that
they're going to be completely
overwhelmed by chaos and the more
stressed they are,
the more the higher the probability that
they're going to suffer ill health for
one reason or another.
So perhaps part of the reason for the
desire to maintain social integrity,
even if you're at the bottom of the
heap,
is because some orders better than none,
especially if you're already stressed to
your limit.
Severe moral judgment may be a key
mechanism by which the social immune
system instantiated and conservative
practices and policies aims to eliminate
exposure to deviant social elements that
may increase the risk of pathogen
exposure.
According to a parasite stress
hypothesis,
authoritarian governments are more
likely to emerge in regions
characterized by a high prevalence of
disease causing pathogens.
Recent cross national evidence is
consistent with this hypothesis,
but there are inferential limitations
associated with that evidence.
We report to studies that address some
of these limitations and provide further
tests of the hypothesis.
This is the paper I mentioned before
from plause one.
Um,
unfortunately I didn't put the title of
it here.
If you type into Google authoritarianism
and parasite prevalence and you look for
plause one p l o s one,
you'll find it right away.
Study one or revealed that parasite
prevalence strongly predicted cross
national differences on measures
assessing individual's authoritarian
personalities and this effect
statistically mediated the relationship
between parasite prevalence and the
authoritarian governance.
The mediation result is inconsistent
with an alternative explanation for
previous findings
to address further limitations
associated with cross national
comparisons.
Study two tested the parasite stress
hypothesis on a sample of traditional
small scale societies.
Revolts re results revealed that
parasite prevalence predicted measures
of authoritarian governance and did so
even when statistically controlling for
other threats to human welfare.
One additional threat.
Famine also uniquely predicted
authoritarianism.
Together these results further
substantiate the parasite stress
hypothesis of authoritarianism and
suggested societal differences and
authoritarian governance result in part
from cultural differences in
individuals,
authoritarians personalities.
So there is a correlation table.
So the correlation between authoritarian
governance and pathogen prevalence is
0.42.
Okay.
That's higher than the correlation
between Iq and academic performance at
the University of Toronto by quite a
substantial margin 0.42 especially in a
sample of this size because it was a
very large sample.
That's about as big a correlation
coefficient as you're ever going to see
between two two variables,
one of which is psychological.
So that would be the,
the,
the uh,
authoritarian is 12 item index of
authoritarian governance.
So one of the things to remember,
it's only a item questionnaire that's
not a very good questionnaire.
So there's a lot of measurement error in
that and that actually in a situation
like this that actually means the true
correlation is higher because lack of
reliability is going to like cause if
your measure isn't reliable and isn't
completely valid than some of what it
measures is going to be noise.
And so the true correlation could easily
be 0.5
fam and adds another 0.26
it's quite staggering.
Now
I want to walk you through some
potential consequences of this and some
of this is speculative in some of it
isn't.
One of the things I want you to remember
is that
the end of World War One,
the biggest flu influenza epidemic and
that was ever recorded in history hit
and it killed four times as many people
as the first world war.
So that's,
you got to keep that in mind.
Or Germany lost the first world war and
they suffered a harsh reparation burden
as a consequence of the peace treaty
that was signed at Versailles.
And then during the 1920s
the German economy collapsed completely
so that people were taking wheelbarrows
full of money to the corner store to buy
bread.
So
you can imagine that those,
the war,
the flu and the catastrophic
catastrophic inflation set the stage for
German political thinking,
certainly what happened to the Germans
could be regarded as immensely chaotic
in a society that's collapsed into
chaos,
you're going to get an unconscious
or conscious demand for the imposition
of order.
And one thing Hitler was good at was
ordered.
You look at that picture on the left
hand side,
that's tens of thousands of people
all organized into basically perfect
squares.
And you remember how the Nazis marched?
They did the goose step and they did an
absolutely precisely
Hitler was certainly willing to
subordinate the individual freedom of
the Germans that the ariens let's say to
his overall vision and believed in fact
that the individual should be
subordinate to the overall vision.
And he was certainly willing to
sacrifice
anyone or anything that deviated from
the,
from inclusion within this pure ordered
body.
So that
that's a photograph of the Nuremberg
Nazi party rally grounds
from quite a distance.
The light that you see that's horizontal
across the bottom is the front of the
stage.
The lights shining upward are the loofah
office,
antiaircraft lights,
all arrayed around the parade ground and
shining straight up.
So use the symbolism of light against
darkness as an adjunct to his political
maneuvering.
You could see the absolute order that's
portrayed in that massive sculpture of
light.
Okay?
You can see in the top left hand corner
there,
the precise precision with with which
everyone is lined up.
So they make perfectly geometrical
patterns.
And then on the right,
and this,
this is a small stadium for a political
gathering compared to what the Nazis
were planning.
Albert speer was planning to build a
stadium for such rallies that would have
had 400,000 seats.
So I think the typical football stadium
has about 60,000
so you see on the right,
everyone perfectly aligned,
everyone perfectly uniform and masses
and masses and rows of people all
ordered in precise perfection.
This is a piece of Nazi propaganda from
the 1930s this,
the rest of this lecture is going to be
very disturbing,
but I want to show you what happened as
far as I can tell.
When Hitler came to power,
his fundamental
goal was to purify what he thought of as
the area in body.
And I want to show you how he went about
doing that.
So that's wording from a Nazi propaganda
folder.
The people of the world will recognize
the Jew as world parasite and there will
be a time when there will be one united
front of all people against the Jewish
world,
parasite and humanity will be freed from
the most severe illness from which it
suffered for thousands of years.
Now,
the reason I picked those words
precisely is because you can see the
body metaphor lying underneath that it's
direct.
It's not,
it's not even subtle.
Now,
these are
pieces of Hitler's spontaneous speech
that we're organized from mine comp.
These are all metaphors of disease that
he used in his speeches and writing.
It's from a book by Richard Koenigsberg,
w called embodied metaphor,
fantasy and history.
Since the state did not possess the
power to master the disease,
the menacing decay of the Reich was
manifest.
The masses feel that the mere fact of
the Jews existences as bad as the
plague.
Politicians tinkering around on the
German national body saw it.
Most of the forms of our general
disease,
but blindly ignored the virus.
At the tail time of the unification,
the inner decay was already in full
swing and the general situation was
deteriorating from year to year.
The Nation did not grow inwardly
healthier,
but obviously languished more and more.
The symptoms of decay of the prewar
period can be reduced to racial causes.
Anybody who wants to cure this era,
which was inwardly sick and rotten,
must first of all sum up the courage to
make clear the causes of this disease.
They think that they must demonstrate
that they are ready for appeasement.
That's the English I believe so as to
stay the deadly cancerous all through a
policy of moderation.
The Jew must take care that the plague
does not die.
If this battle should not come,
Germany would decay and it basket sync
to ruin like a rotting corpse.
You can see in the right today an
example of mortal dk.
The 1st of May can only,
it can be only the liberation of the
nation spirit from the infection of
internationalism and the restoration
health of all the peoples
against the infection of materialism
against the Jewish pestilence,
we must hold a loft,
a flaming ideal.
One of the things that's also extremely
interesting about Hitler's use of
propaganda was his intense fascination
with fire.
And the thing about fire is that it's a
purifying elements to purifying elements
symbolically as well.
You know,
when,
when the Second World War was coming to
a close and things had gone
catastrophically wrong for the Germans,
Hitler became extremely disenchanted
with his people and undertook actions
that were by all appearances designed to
increase the degree to which Germany was
destroyed.
And it seems to me that that,
and this is,
this is this kind of ties into the
Friday and idea of a death wish.
I think that Hitler had this fantasy
that he laid out over his whole,
that the best thing that could happen to
life if it wasn't pure was that it
should be burnt in fire.
And I think that's what happened in the
Second World War.
I think he lived that right out to its
ultimate conclusion because he shot
himself in a bunker when Berlin was
burning,
you know?
And,
and how fire has historically been used
for purification?
You know,
it's not for no reason that many
cultures burn bodies after people die.
Okay.
The restoration to health of our people
must start from the restoration to
health of the body politic.
I give the order to burn out down to the
raw flesh,
the ulcers of this poisoning of the
wells.
You can't get much more direct than
that.
Okay.
The only way permanently to cure disease
conditions is to disclose their causes.
Infections in countries lead to a
crippling of intelligence and of the
forces of resistance.
This is the battle against a veritable
world sickness which threatens to infect
the people's a plague,
which devastates whole peoples and
international pestilence.
The international carrier of the
Bacillus must be fought.
If within this community,
one state is infected,
that infection is decisive for all alike
in Europe,
no common life of the nations and
possible is possible when amongst their
number.
There are some who are suffering from a
poisonous infection and who openly
profess their desire to infect others
with the same disease.
We have a very real interest in seeing
it,
seeing to it that this bolshevist plague
shall not spread over Europe.
Same terminology applied to the
Communists,
the communist threat moving in from the
east.
National Socialism has made our people
and therefore the right immune from a
Bolshevik infection.
For hundreds of years,
Germany was good enough to receive these
elements.
Jews,
although they possessed nothing except
infectious,
political and physical diseases,
only when this Jewish Bacillus effecting
the life of peoples has been removed.
Can one hope to establish a cooperation
amongst the nations?
Well,
you get the picture.
I want to show you something now.
This is from a particularly pernicious
propaganda film that was produced by the
Nazis.
1344 2041
yeah.
Okay.
Choice.
They settled there mercilessly.
Totally different racial elements differ
from us.
We probably would never been bothered by
them
and
especially
the Romans brought about the evolution
of the trade and migratory traits soon
spread across the open Mediterranean
area.
While some of them settled in the large
urban centers of the Mediterranean,
others wandered relentlessly on across
Spain,
France,
southern Germany,
and England.
Everywhere.
They made themselves unwelcome in Spain
and France.
The people grows overlay against the
13th or 14th century,
mainly the German
culture,
creative Germans colonizing the east
until they finally found the gigantic
reservoir in the Polish and Russian
sections of in
the 19th century with its model.
Ideas about human equality and freedom
is a great lip.
Eastern Europe,
they spread across the entire continent
during the 19th and 20th centuries and
then across the
parallel to the Jewish monitoring
throughout the world is the migration of
similarly restless animal,
the
rat seven parasites from the very
beginning,
the most,
they might read it in gigantic Korea or
Russia
or the middle of the 18th century.
It's straight over all of Europe,
where the end of the 19th century was
the growing and shipping traffic.
They dispossessed of America,
Africa,
and
harass turn up.
They carry the structure of the lab,
but as frying mankind's goods and
spreading diseases this way,
so just cholera,
dysentery,
leprosy and typhoid fever
solidly and unusually a beard and a
massive born.
They represent the elements of
sneakiness and subterranean disruption
among animals
just as the Jews knew,
among
parasite,
responsible for a large part of the
international crime.
On that 32 the Jews who made up only 1%
of the world's population,
about 34% of the world's don't members,
47%
47% are for the games of chance percent
look international crime organizations,
98% of dealers and prostitutes
in the jargon of international gangsters
stem from Hebrew and yiddish words,
lease cars,
the automobiles immediately liberal
theory,
the equality of all when they're
older.
Well,
I'll show you the four minutes
recognizable
when spot is racial origin
is that the oldest tries to hide his
origin.
When a mom
still wearing cap towns
in western European clothes repairing,
infiltrate the Western civilization
and of course these ghetto Jews don't
get moved to,
well,
they're clean and European bloats
somewhat more wanted that.
How did you,
was Oberlin,
their fathers and grandfathers,
but that's not really noticeable here in
the second and third generation.
I don't relate to.
They tried to add just like the host
people
instincts and let themselves be the
seat,
but this mimicry is the same as they
are.
They will then lies the enormous danger.
These assimilated was remain forever
foreign bodies and the organism or the
host vehicles regardless.
I love Arizona.
That film has the dubious distinction of
being perhaps the most evil single piece
of propaganda the Nazi's ever produced,
which is really saying something,
you know?
Yeah.
I mentioned something like this a couple
of weeks ago.
The thing that's so frightening about
this I think is that
okay
it,
it shows you in some sense how
delicately balanced society has to be in
order not to fall prey to a catastrophe
on one side or a catastrophe on the
other.
Because what we seem to be seeing here,
at least in part
is the
consequence of the overgeneralization
of a deeply inborn human trait,
some of whose consequences appear to be
necessary both for survival and
productivity.
It would be such an easier problem if
you could take the cause which is at
least in so far as this argument runs,
which is sensitivity to discussed
and just assume that that in it in its
entirety as a form of pathology,
but you can't do that because
sensitivity to discussed does protect
people from pathogens,
but if you push it too far while then
things seem to fall apart in an
absolutely atrocious way.
One of the things that I've found so
illuminating about this line of research
is that it answers a question that
people have struggled with for a very
long period of time,
which is how is it possible for human
beings to dehumanize other people?
And the answer to this,
the answer that you would derive from
this line of reasoning makes the
question quite mixed.
The answer quite obvious.
You just associate health with what
you're trying to promote and to validate
and you associate that with purity and
then you associate the other with
illness and disease.
And then you have a metaphor lying
underneath that that's just ready for
the taking.
And it's a powerful metaphor and it
still seems to have immense effect on
people in so far as it is parasite
prevalence that predicts authoritarian
political attitudes.
Now,
nope.
One of the things I don't understand is
how the,
one of the things we talked about in the
existential lectures was
the existential idea that one of the
things that promoted the development of
totalitarian states was the willingness
of the people who were occupied by the
totalitarian ideology to falsify their
own personal experience,
to keep it in accordance with the
totalitarian claims.
So there was the idea of,
of the,
of the lie,
the Frankel makes much of,
I think maybe the lie in part is
it's gotta be something like the denial
of your own identity with the
vulnerability that you want to shunt off
into others and persecute,
you know,
the taking to yourself of everything
that constitutes purity and perfection.
And then the lady,
the overburdening the other with
everything that you don't want to be
true about yourself.
It's true in the,
what you don't want to be true about
yourself is partly that actuality of
physical degeneration and decay.
But it seems to me that the reality of
moral degeneration and decay is a very,
very close analog to that they stack on
top of one another.
And so maybe the lie is that you're not
that,
but they are.
And that provides at least a partial
answer
anyways,
I don't have much more to say about that
today.
So maybe we could take some time for
questions
if you have any,
uh,
social,
immune system
balances better overall because you
think about children who are brazen
as they grow up to be adults with these
like crazy.
So it's almost like
a less conservative views.
It's almost like you're looking at it.
Oh,
that's interesting idea.
Well that's an interesting metaphoric
idea.
So the idea there would be that by
insisting upon radical purity,
you actually weaken a society a just
like you would weaken and an immune
system.
But then if you expose yourself to those
ideas,
then when you go into
a broad spectrum of like whatever kind
of,
well,
that's a pretty good,
that would be pretty good defense of the
idea of a liberal education.
You know,
because on the one hand,
if you're a fundamentalist,
you're going to say,
well,
you,
you're only going to be taught the ideas
that are exactly in keeping with the
most pure of doctrines of your people.
But as you,
as you pointed out,
quite rightly,
that means that the second you step
outside of that protective influence and
you hear any other ideas,
you're gone because you have no defense
them whatsoever.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's like a resilience argument
fundamentally.
You know,
the idea and the liberal association
with openness would be something akin to
that,
right?
Because open people are interested new
experiences and new ideas and they value
them.
Now
the reason that opened people are
interested in value them seems to be
something pretty primordial.
They find new intro,
new ideas,
deeply meaningful and the tract.
But you can,
you can certainly be sure that
throughout human history there's been
this tension between whether opening up
produces more longterm strengthening,
then rigidified and closing down.
Well it's a gamble.
You know,
liberal countries definitely take the
ladder strategy and you know,
there hasn't been a war of any
consequence between two liberal
democracies.
So there is some historical evidence to
suggest that it's working.
They're peaceful societies,
general speaking internally as well.
So other questions?
Yes.
One of them.
Well,
most of this research is still in its
infancy and the,
you know,
the strength,
the strength of the association between
socioeconomic status and disgust
sensitivity.
I would say that's something that's been
more suggested than something that's,
you know,
demonstrated and attributed to increased
disgust,
sensitivity at the lower end of the
spectrum.
So,
yeah,
well,
everything I told you today,
it's still a hypothesis.
You know,
it's because it's all new.
It's new,
it's all,
all of this data has been gathered
within the last 15 years,
10 or 15 years.
And so people are still trying to sort
out what it means.
I mean,
I think that study I showed you showing
the correlation of point,
was it,
what was it?
Point four 5.4 9.42 b between a
authoritarian political attitudes and
parasite prevalence.
That's,
that's a jaw dropping study.
Who the hell would have ever guessed
that?
You know,
when it makes sense in retrospect,
when you look at,
say,
Hitler's propaganda and the discussions
in light of that data.
But as far as I could tell,
well,
this sort of material just hasn't been
brought together before by historians.
I do you know that that's a good
question too because it's not exactly
clear.
I don't think it's exactly clear why
authoritarian attitudes would mean.
What are the implications of the paper
fundamentally is that there's,
there's a reason that authoritarian
attitudes appear when there's parasite
prevalence.
The court,
the association is very strong,
so one of the things you could infer
from that was that there's actually some
utility in it now.
Perhaps not.
Perhaps it's only that if you're so
stressed by disease and parasites and so
forth,
you just don't want to have anything to
do with any other kind of uncertainty or
maybe it's that you revert to extremely
traditional and order bound ways of
interacting in an attempt to decrease
the probability that you'll be exposed,
exposed to the parasites.
I don't know.
Do you think it's related to
Zombie survival TV shows and infection
yet the band together?
Oh yeah,
sure.
It's exactly the same sort of thing.
Yeah.
The funny thing,
the Zombie,
the Zombie idea though puts a weird
twist on it that was more associated
with your hypothesis,
which is that,
you know,
the zombies are also often mindlessly
obedient and then they become
diseased and decaying and dad and,
and,
and uh,
uh,
cannibalistic.
So
it definitely does seem to be the case
that if you take many virtues too far,
they produce exactly the consequence
that the person that was pushing them
wants to avoid.
So that seems to me to be a really good
argument against the extension of
the idea of orderliness too far.
It's going to kick back and produce a
hell of a lot more chaos than you think
if you don't keep it in balance with the
other.
You know,
because one of the things that the big
five model seems to indicate is that in
order to keep yourself oriented in the
environment,
you have to have five dimensions of
value because otherwise there wouldn't
be five dimensions of value,
right.
And maybe if you collapse everything
into a single dimension,
you tighten down so much that they can
no longer function properly.
And then everything tends to deteriorate
into chaos and there's gotta be a
reason.
There's five dimensions,
you know,
so you have to regulate your social
behavior.
That would be extroversion at least to
some degree.
You have to respond to threat and
punishment.
You have to care for or exploit other
people roughly.
No,
you have to care for other people and
care for yourself.
That would be agreeableness.
I would say disgust,
conscientiousness at length,
and then of course openness is basically
the intake of new information.
You have to solve all five of those
problems in order for things to remain
in some kind of reasonable balance.
You might even be able to make a case
that if you want to keep a society
optimally organized,
given that there's variability on each
of those dimensions,
you have to keep a conversation going
between everyone in that five
dimensional space regardless of where
they're located on the,
on the distribution.
Because
if the idea is to optimize the fit of
the society to the shape of the
environment at any given time,
that's going to be a very complicated
problem because you don't exactly know
what shape the environment is.
So if you could keep the dialogue going
between all the interested parties,
maybe you can move this society along
properly and keep it matched enough to
the environment so that it can stay
healthy.
And if you tilt it too much in the
direction of any of these unit
dimensional values,
then it's gonna.
It's going to increase the probability
that it'll collapse.
That could be because otherwise I can't
understand why there would be five
dimensions.
They must be,
they're necessary,
obviously,
in some sense.
So
other questions?
So what do you think?
Yup.
Correlation between
one sort of conservative.
Yeah.
Well,
I made,
I made an analogy.
Yeah.
Uh,
which one was that?
Well,
if your sales go ahead and do their own
thing,
then you develop cancer.
Right?
My point being that if you're going to
organize,
because I individual entities into a
higher order structure,
there's obviously some minimum of
cooperation.
And what would you call similarity,
uniformity between those members or it's
not going to work.
And the question is always how uniform
you should be.
I mean the [inaudible],
the idea was that you should be uniform
and everything,
you know,
basically you would be just one person.
I think that probably does,
that does bear some similarity to the
case that you made because what you see
in extremely authoritarian states as
they are trying to reduce the,
the,
the human complexity to the
manifestation of a single personality.
And the problem with that is that if
that single personalities matched
perfectly to the environment,
it's going to be extremely efficient.
But the probability that it's going to
be perfectly matched is basically zero.
There's too many possible environments.
And so if the authoritarians push all
the variability out of the state,
which is what they want to do,
then it's going to weaken it across
time,
not strengthen it.
I mean,
most political battles you have to fight
on the turf of your opponent,
right?
Because they're not gonna listen,
like left wingers and right wingers
never listened to each other.
So if you want to communicate with
someone who is on the right,
you have to communicate using the
language of the right.
If you want to communicate with someone
on the left,
do you have to communicate using the
language on the left,
at least roughly speaking because
they're,
the values differ.
So the strongest case you would make
against right wing authoritarianism
would be that the authoritarianism
itself pushed too far would endanger the
values that the conservatives themselves
water maintain.
That's a hard argument to refute.
That wasn't their prime example not too
long ago where there they did a study
where they change the semantic,
just like the wording of something.
Yeah.
Pollution.
I see you.
If you appeal to purity concerns when
you're doing environmental,
um,
agitating,
let's say,
or messaging purity concerns are much
more effective or on conservatives.
So you can show them,
you know,
pictures of polluted water and that sort
of thing.
They're quite responsive to that kind of
thing.
You know,
rather than we should respect our animal
friends,
which would be something that would be
more appealing to someone who's on the
liberal side of things.
Because they tend to be more
egalitarian.
So what do you think about having been
shown that film?
Is that an acceptable thing to do in a
class?
What did people say?
Anybody think?
Not you can say so.
I'm curious.
Okay.
So that was all right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I'd have to bar the doors
otherwise.
Yeah.
Yes.
Well I don't like,
I don't think that you can,
you can combat anything.
You can,
you don't understand.
The problem is,
is that understanding some things isn't
very pleasant,
you know,
because once you understand them,
this is a Rogerian perspective.
Once you understand them.
Yeah.
To understand something is to see how
it's allowable.
He human,
otherwise you don't understand it.
And that's not good.
That's rough.
There's like a weird paradox that
exists.
The,
while I'm watching this,
I feel that my viewpoints,
uh,
would be,
if someone who embodied the idea alone
that isn't a bill,
where did directly be opposed to like my
position,
but,
and feel that my views and way of life,
you know,
living in Canadian society,
uh,
is cancerous.
But here I am sitting like watching this
film and I'm thinking of like,
Oh God,
I can't imagine that they can't.
It's just a cancer,
isn't it?
So
yeah.
Yeah.
Well I mean the Nazis claims very much
antithetical to western liberal claims
in every possible way.
I mean they viewed in modern society,
we think of being cosmopolitan has a
virtue.
You know what it means is no matter
where you go,
you're,
you could adapt for the Nazis.
That meant you'd been fatally corrupted.
How are you
attached to a persona or two,
one personality trait of themselves and
so cyclical apology happens.
I was thinking that we do something like
this all the time when we make a mistake
where we said like there's a part of us
that is irresponsible that I just need
to like just crush your,
just the control entirely.
I just want to be this copy intelligent
person.
You want to move and we try to crush
everything else.
That's a good segue into the existential
idea of the lie
because the psychoanalysts constantly
reminded people that there was very much
danger in cutting off a particular part
of you and regarding it as diseased,
you know,
and,
and part of it,
I should have remembered that and you
know,
part of young's claim because he spent a
lot of time thinking about the Nazis,
was that
if you alienate yourself from part of
yourself,
then you're going to do the same thing
to anyone who resembles that part of
yourself.
And so you have to be very careful about
doing that.
You know,
this guy named Eric [inaudible] who was
one of young students and he wrote a
book at the end of the second world war
called depth psychology to new ethic.
And one of the things that noise
proposed,
he was Jewish by the way.
One of the things that Norman proposed
was that you don't try to be any better
than you are.
And by that he meant to not engage in
that kind of radical splitting.
He didn't mean you shouldn't try to
improve your moral character.
He meant that it's very dangerous to
pretend that you're entirely pure,
you know,
and,
and
it's a tough one because you don't want
to eliminate the possibility of moral
striving,
obviously,
because then there's no op,
right?
There's nothing to do that,
but it certainly has to be tempered with
some,
well,
probably tempered with compassion.
And maybe that's the idea of tempering
and the personality trait domain.
You know,
one of the things I do with people who
are agreeable because they don't stand
up for themselves very well.
If they're agreeable and conscientious,
I encouraged them to tell the truth,
you know,
because if they're being oppressed and
then they get resentful,
which always happens to agreeable
people,
then I make a case that they have to
temper their agreeableness with some
conscientiousness and adopted as a moral
obligation to speak out on behalf of
themselves,
despite the fact that they won't like
the conflict,
you know?
And I guess if you're an orderly person.
Yeah.
My wife had a dream once about this that
I just remembered.
She's quite an orderly person.
And she had a dream at one point that
she walked into an auditorium that was
full of people like this.
And she came down to the front of the
auditorium where all the men and the
dogs were and sat with them.
And that was a dream about the
relationship between orderliness and
agreeableness,
is that,
you know,
if you're orderly,
the problem is you can get so damn
orderly that can't stand people.
You can't stand men and dogs,
which was what her dream was basically,
you know,
she was making them equivalent,
so dog shed all over the house and they
know they're annoying and stupid and you
know,
I guess men fit into that category too.
But her dream pretty much said that that
was the proper place to sit and that
that was a very,
it was a very intelligent dream in that
regard.
You know?
So you temporary orderliness with
compassion.
Likely that'd be my guess.
So,
and that was certainly not something
that happened with the Nazis.
There was no compassion at all.
Only the desire to exterminate and to,
and to,
and to kill.
All right guys.
We'll see you on
Tuesday one more week.
Kay.
[inaudible].